The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hello, welcome.
So as you might expect, there
is yet another announcement.
So this time, Exam 3, the last
of the midterms, same rules--
everything is roughly the same.
Walker, next Wednesday,
7:30 to 9:30.
No recitations on
the day of the exam.
Coverage through Lecture 18,
which is next lecture, coverage
through Recitation 16--
that's tomorrow--
homeworks 1 to 10.
Homework 10 won't be graded--
there will be solutions posted.
3 pages, your old 2 plus 1.
No calculators, blah, blah,
blah-- same as last time.
Designed to be one
hour, two hours
to complete-- same as last time.
There'll be a review session--
there'll be one on
Monday at 3 PM in 36-112
and, of course, you can
ask any review questions
you'd like at any of
the open office hours,
but there'll be a formal review
in 36-112 on Monday at 3:00.
Prior term exams have
already been posted
and if you have a
conflict, please tell me
because I have to find
rooms and a proctor.
OK, questions, comments--
completely routine
at this point, right?
No problems-- everybody
knows what they're doing?
It'll be fun, it'll
be enjoyable--
smile.
Questions, comments?
OK, so what I want to talk today
about is DT, signal-processing.
So formerly, I'm going to talk
about things like DT Fourier
series.
Next time we'll talk about
DT Fourier Transform,
but the context for that--
the reason we do this--
is because the discrete
time approaches are so
useful for processing signals.
And I want to motivate
that by thinking
about how signal processing
has been viewed historically.
For over the past
20 or 30 years,
there's been enormous
interest in signal processing
and most of that interest
evolved out of CT applications
that we wanted to make better.
We wanted to make our
radio reception better,
we wanted to make
telephone reception better,
hi-fis work better,
we wanted to make
television work better,
photography, x-rays,
blah, blah, blah.
There were lots
of reasons why we
wanted to be able to
alter the signals that
were available to us.
So for example, in radio--
how do you alter the signal
so as to reduce static?
In the early radios,
there was a big problem
with automatic gain control.
So as you went over
the hills, the line
of sight to the
radio station changed
and that changed the gain
so there was an interest
in controlling gain.
So there were lots
of applications
where we wanted to account for
deficiencies in the hardware
and that gave rise to the
notion of signal processing.
Those signal
processing applications
were largely in continuous
time, because the signals were
largely in continuous time--
all that's changed.
Now when you say
signal processing,
you're almost always
mean discrete.
And there's a very
good reason for it
and it's digital electronics.
Digital electronics
are very inexpensive
and they work very well.
I want to give just one
example chosen from my history.
So like most teenage people--
I was teenage once, right?
It was a long time ago,
but I was one once.
And like most teenage
types, even then
we got afflicted
with the audio hi-fi
listen to music virus problem.
The good news is I recovered--
I'm fully functional,
it's gone, right?
So you have every reason to
think that you'll recover,
but that was a problem.
I was interested in hi-fi
and that was a hard problem.
So if you think about how do
you make a speaker system,
one of the problems
that you get when
you try to design
a speaker system
is reproducing low frequencies.
And my guess is that you're as
interested in low frequencies
as we were back then.
The problem with
low frequencies is
that if you have just
a speaker, the speaker
has an electromagnet.
The electromagnet moves so
that it pushes the cone.
The cone pushes air this way,
but if cone is coming out,
it also pulls air that way.
So that's a problem because
that means it can do that
and the person who is
over here hears nothing.
That's especially bad at
low frequencies for reasons
I won't go into because
the wavelengths are long,
but that's the problem.
So what do you do?
Well, you put it in a box.
So instead of having
your speaker in space,
you put the speaker in a box.
Now when the cone
goes that way, the air
gets compressed
toward the person--
that's our second person.
And now the air that goes
this way is constrained
to the box, so it
doesn't interfere,
but what's the new problem?
So putting it in the
box solves one problem,
but it introduces a new problem.
What's the new problem?
AUDIENCE: Box vibrates.
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
box will vibrate--
even worse.
AUDIENCE: Negative pressure.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Native pressure.
So how does that show up
as a performance problem?
That's exactly right.
What's the problem
that's generated
because of the negative
pressure in the box?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So there's
something to do with gain--
that's exactly right.
Because of the
negative pressure,
what happens to
the speaker cone?
AUDIENCE: Not be able to push.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Yes, it can't move--
you put a load on it.
If in order to
come out, you have
to generate negative pressure,
but the negative pressure's
going to pull it back in.
So the problem is that you
put the speaker in the box,
now you no longer have the short
circuit of the acoustic path.
However, you've now
introduced a load,
which makes the speaker
much harder to move.
Everyone with me?
So the problem was you
put the speaker in the box
and now the speaker, which was
making a lot of air motion,
makes very little air
motion because of the box.
So what do you do next?
Make the box big.
OK, well that works for a while.
Ideally if you were trying to
build a speaker for this room,
you would make a box this size.
Well, that's kind of
an architectural waste,
so that's not really
the right solution.
So here's an acoustic
solution that was very popular
when I was your age.
So this is called a reflex port.
So the idea is make
a hole in the box--
so if you make a
hole in the box,
OK, now you're back
to the same problem
that if the speaker
comes out this way, then
it sucks air that way--
that's bad.
So what you do instead
is you put a tube
and if you make the
length of the tube exactly
the right size, there is
mass entrained in the tube.
And then you have a system
where the air is springy,
but there's mass in here and
you get a mass spring dashpot.
So now when this is
going in and out,
the air goes in and
out of this tube,
and if you adjust the
length of the tube
so you get the mass right, you
can get them going in phase.
Anyone have a clue what
I just talked about?
The idea was to use mass
spring dashpot resonance theory
to change the acoustics
of a speaker box
so you get more low
frequencies out.
That was the way we thought
about speaker design back then.
The speakers that I bought were
the Electric Voice Interface
A's, right?
At that time, they
cost about $1,500,
I was making $600 a month--
so times have changed slightly.
So $1,500 was then a fortune,
but I had to have them, right?
There was any question.
And the way these worked
was like the reflex design.
So in the reflex
design, we had the port
that was tuned so the mass
resonated against the stiffness
of the air.
Here what you did--
this was not a speaker.
This is the speaker--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
--and the idea was
that you adjust the
mass and stiffness
of this big passive thing.
There were no electrical
wires hooked up
to that thing-- that was
called a passive resonator.
It was tuned so that when the
8-inch speaker up here was
trying to move, it would
move in resonance so that it
was out of phase with the
8-inch speaker up on the top
so they were both going
in and out the same time.
Same idea as the reflex, but
you could get a bigger motion
from this passive
resonator than you
could with the acoustic reflex.
So the next big advance
was by Amar Bose.
Bose was here at
the time-- he was
a professor in
electroengineering at that time
and he invented the
Bose 901s, which
is something
everybody had to have.
What Bose did that was
extraordinarily clever was
he used really
chintzy speakers--
CTS speakers, 4-inch diameter.
They had absolutely crummy
frequency response--
flat up to a couple of hundred
Hertz and then their response
fell roughly with one pole--
so that by the time you get
out to the highest frequencies
that we can hear, the
response is greatly
attenuated-- like 40 decibels.
40 decibels is a factor
of 100 in pressure.
So the problem is
that these speakers
had exactly the same
problems that we
had in the acoustic
reflex problem,
except they were even worse.
This was an 8-inch speaker,
this is a 4-inch speaker,
so they were even worse.
But what Bose did--
he took advantage
of electronics.
He put an electronic
signal processing box
to put the inverse filter, so
the box preprocessed the sound
to boost the
frequencies that he knew
the speaker would attenuate.
So this box was filled with
op-amps, gains, buffers--
all the kinds of
things you know about,
which were then just
barely available.
That box cost $1,000 back
then because that was very
state-of-the-art.
So the idea was that
he switched the problem
from being acoustics problem
to an electronics problem--
very clever.
Today we go one more step and
we do the signal processing
digitally.
So any modern stereo system has
a discrete time filter in it.
The idea is that you take
the signal that's coming off
the source, like an MP3--
you take an MP3-type source,
you run it through a digital
filter--
this is a filter that works
on numbers, not on volts--
and so you convert the
source from the MP3
into a stream of
numbers that gets
crunched digitally, giving
rise to a different stream
of numbers, which
you then convert back
into an analog signal.
This is the approach you find
in every modern stereo system.
The reason being that
it works so well.
Here's a chip, the Texas
Instruments TAS3004,
which was specifically
designed for car stereos.
It's got amazing specs--
it has two channels,
state-of-the-art converting
rates, state-of-the-art
digitisation.
It has a processor
internally that
runs at 100 mega
instructions per second.
It implements all the common
things-- treble, volume,
loudness, everything
you can imagine--
and it costs $9.63 off
Digi-Key in units of one.
And if you buy units of
500, they are $5.20 apiece--
a trivial amount of
money by any standard.
So the idea then is that
it's just very effective
to do number-crunching
digitally.
So that's where we want
to talk about-- we want
to talk about the same
kinds of Fourier transforms
and so forth that we've
talked about with CT signals,
but we want to know
the new set of rules
that apply when the signals
are discrete in time.
OK, everybody with me?
So this is just a
little bit of review.
You'll remember that we
started with discrete time,
we did examples in
discrete time when
we were thinking about feedback,
then we went on to the CT
and thought about
feedback systems
and so forth, then
we did CT Fourier
because I think the Fourier
stuff is easier to see in CT.
Now we're folding back to do DT.
So it's been about six weeks
since we talked about DT,
so a little bit of a refresher.
We're going to be thinking about
frequency responses, right?
That was the basis of the
Fourier transform, that's
going to be the basis
of the Fourier signal
processing in discrete time.
And the idea of
frequency analysis
starts with the idea
of an eigenfunction.
The eigenfunctions for
a discrete time system
are very similar to
the eigenfunctions
for a continuous time, but
they're different, right?
The eigenfunctions
for a CT system
are complex exponentials, e
to the st. Nod your head--
it'll make me feel good to think
that you can remember that we
did e to the st at one point.
So the eigenfunctions
for CT systems
are complex exponentials, e to
the st. Eigenfunctions for DT
systems are complex geometrics.
Complex geometrics in
DT play the same role
as complex exponentials in
CT, and they play that role
for exactly the same reason.
So when we wanted to prove that
the complex exponentials were
eigenfunctions of LTI systems,
we took the complex exponential
and we convolved it with the
impulse response of an LTI
system.
All LTI systems can be
represented by their impulse
response.
If you convolve any
real-valued function
with a complex
exponential, you get back
a complex exponential
of the same shape,
but possibly different
complex amplitude.
The same thing happens in DT.
So in order to see
that that's true,
we think about the input
to an LTI system being
z to the n-- complex
exponentials,
so z is some complex
number, z to the n
is the evolution of
the complex geometric
as a function of time.
We let the system be
represented by the unit sample
response, which is analogous
to the unit impulse response.
And we simply convolve
the unit sample response
with the complex
geometric, and if you
go through the
convolution's thumb--
it's a thumb now
because it's DT--
you find that the output
has the same base, z,
that the input did
but now the amplitude
has been modified by
the value of the system
function evaluated at
the location, z, OK?
We did this before--
this is review.
Similarly, if you think about
representing a discrete time
system in terms of
a linear difference
equation with constant
co-efficients,
you can see that type
of system can always
be represented by the
ratio of polynomials in z.
The same as with CT--
we had the ratio of
polynomials in s.
Here it's the polynomials in z.
And if we want to evaluate
that h of z thing, the system
function, there's
a very easy way
to do it since
it's a polynomial.
There's nothing different
about polynomials in z
and polynomials in s in far
as their being polynomials.
The fact that
they're a polynomial
means you can factor
the numerator,
you can factor the
denominator, you
can think about poles and zeros,
and you can evaluate the system
function.
After you've factored the
numerator and the denominator,
think about each contribution.
So z0 minus q0--
so if I have a zero
at q0 and I want
to know how big is
the eigenvalue at z0,
I think about the
arrow that connects
the 0 to the point of interest.
And I can say something
about the magnitude
by the length of the
arrow and the phase
by the angle of the arrow--
same as CT.
And I get the same
divide and conquer idea.
If I know how one 0 works and
if I know how one pole works,
I can combine the responses
to the numerous poles
in a complicated system
in order to figure out how
the complicated system works.
I can think about the poles
and zeros one at a times,
just like I did for CT.
So the magnitude is determined
by the product and division
of all the magnitude
factors and the angle
is determined by the sum and
difference of all the angle
factors.
OK, I'm going over this
quickly, but that's
because I'm expecting
that you know this,
you just need to be reminded.
If we want to think about
the frequency response,
we do the same
thing we did in CT.
We like complex
geometrics, so we
try to think about the
eternal cosine waves
as being expressed in terms
of complex geometrics.
The difference is that
now we think about this e
to the j omega 0 end-term.
So we had the same form--
we had e to the j omega 0 t.
We thought about that
as a complex exponential
with a frequency omega 0.
Now we're thinking about
e to the j omega 0 n as z
being this e to the
j omega 0 thing, OK?
It's the same thing-- it's
still Euler's equation,
we're just parsing
it differently.
We used to think of it as
a complex exponential, now
we think of it as a
complex geometric--
that's the only difference.
So now what we
need to do if we're
thinking about the response
to the cosine of omega 0 n,
we have to think about adding
two complex exponentials, one
at z0 and one at z1, where
z0 is e to the j omega
0 an z1 is e to the
minus j omega 0, OK?
Then the response, since the z0
to the n is an eigenfunction,
the answer is just
that same eigenfunction
premultiplied by the system
function evaluated at z0
and similarly here for z1.
So we get an expression here
that looks for all the world,
except that this is the base
of a geometric sequence.
Except for that, it looks just
the same as the CT example
from before.
Just like CT, the
system function
has conjugate
symmetry and, in fact,
that's for the same reason too.
So you can see that
there's complex symmetry
just by thinking about
the expansion in terms
of the z transform.
And if you think about the fact
that the h of n's are all real,
taking the complex
conjugate of this side
is the same as taking the
complex conjugate of that.
The complex conjugate
of a sum is the sum
of the complex conjugates.
The only thing that's
imaginary is that.
So the only thing that happens
is that the sign changes.
So it's those complex
conjugates' relationship in DT,
just the same as there is in
CT for exactly the same reason.
And finally, we get
our final answer,
which is that if we want to know
about the frequency response,
we therefore think about what
was the magnitude and angle
of the system function.
We only need to look at
one of the frequencies
since we know the
frequency response has
conjugate symmetry,
and we can figure out
the response to cos omega n.
It's still cos omega
n, except the magnitude
is different by the magnitude
of the system function
and phase delayed by the
angle of the system function--
everything looks
exactly the same.
The one thing that's different--
now we're getting something
a little more interesting--
the one thing
that's different is
that we evaluate
the system function
when we're interested to
find the frequency response.
The thing we need to do is
evaluate the system function
on the unit circle.
If we wanted to know the
frequency response for a CT
system, the frequency response
for a CT system lives where?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: J
omega-axis, right?
Here, the frequency response
lives on the unit circle.
That's the only
difference and that
means that the vector
diagrams work precisely
the same way, except that
we don't connect them up
to the j omega-axis.
We connect them up
to the unit circle.
So where is DC?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: DC means cos
omega n where omega is 0.
Where is that?
Where was DC in CT?
Frequency response lives
on the j omega-axis.
Where is DC?
AUDIENCE: 0.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 0.
Where is DC in a DT system?
AUDIENCE: 1.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1, OK?
It's because we've
shifted from thinking
about complex
exponentials to thinking
about complex geometrics.
So now DC lives on the
unit circle at the place
where the angle is 0, right?
So now we have to think
about things of this form.
If we want omega
0 to be 0, we need
to have this number be
e to the 0, which is 1.
So the DC response--
the thing that we plot--
we're going to plot frequency
response just the same
as we did in CT.
They're going to have the
same trick they had in CT.
In CT, the system function
has a non-zero answer
throughout the entire s-plane.
In DT, the system function
has a non-zero response
in the entire z-plane.
The frequency response in CT
lives on the j omega-axis,
the frequency response in
DT lives on the unit circle,
right?
But the frequency
response itself
is simply a plot of
the magnitude and angle
as a function of omega.
I should mention
that I sneakily use
a different symbol for omega.
I like to use a little omega for
a CT and capital Omega for DT.
The reason I like to do
that is that the dimensions
are different, right?
When we think about
little omega 0,
we're thinking about
cosine of omega 0 t.
When we think about
this one, we're
thinking about
cosine of omega 0 n.
Can somebody tell me
something different about
little and capital Omega 0?
What's different about them?
Anything?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The little
one goes to infinity.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
The little one goes
to infinity, that's correct.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The little
one [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you
can think about omega 0--
omega 0 has dimensions
like radian per second,
where omega 0 has the
dimensions of radians, right?
So the dimension will be
completely different--
that will be very important
when we think about systems.
So the last two
weeks of the course,
we'll think about systems that
convert CT to DT and back.
When we're doing
that conversion,
it's very important
to keep track
of how the frequencies change
and this dimensional difference
will be very handy to help us
remember how to convert one
into the other.
So that's the reason for
keeping them separate--
so they're
dimensionally distinct.
So all we need to do then
to think about the frequency
response-- in CT, the
frequency response
would be the magnitude and angle
plotted versus little omega 0.
All we do that's different is
we plot against capital Omega 0.
Capital Omega 0 specifies
the angle on the unit circle.
So if the angle is 0,
we pick out 0 frequency.
We think about that
as having two pieces--
there's the piece
associated with the pole,
there's the piece that's
associated with the 0.
The 0 is in the top,
so we take the length
of the top divided by
the length in the bottom,
and that tells us the magnitude
is 0, which is a number bigger
than 1, right?
Because the pole's
in the bottom--
pole's the short one,
pole's in the bottom.
And as you increase
capital Omega,
you sweep out the
frequency response.
So by the time you
get over to pi,
the length of the vector
associated with the pole
is bigger than the length of
the vector associated with 0,
so now you're less than 1, OK?
So everything's
exactly the same as CT
except that we're looking
at the unit circle
rather than looking
at the j omega-axis.
The same sort of thing happens
for negative frequency,
just like it did in
CT, the only difference
being that in CT, we were
computing the frequency axis
by looking at the j omega-axis.
In DT, we're computing
the frequency axis
by looking at the unit circle.
There is one huge difference.
OK, so summary,
everything's the same
except we look at
the unit circle--
except frequency responses
are now periodic.
Someone previously said
that one of the differences
between little omega big Omega
is that little omega goes
to infinity.
That's absolutely true.
What happens when big
Omega goes to infinity?
Well, angles wrap.
So if you think
about this diagram--
if you start with
capital Omega being
0, by the time you get over
here capital Omega is pi.
If you keep increasing,
you'll come back here--
if you keep increasing,
you go again.
The big difference
between CT and DT
is that the DT
complex exponentials
are periodic in 2 pi--
every 2 pi, they
repeat themselves.
Because of that DT system
functions repeat themselves.
So if you think about
evaluating the system
function at some
frequency omega 2,
which happens to be
omega 1 plus 2 pi k,
you get the same thing as if
you had evaluated the system
function and omega 1 because
the frequency e to the j omega
2 is the same as the
frequency e to the j omega
1 because of the
periodicity of angles.
Is that clear?
So we get something that's
very different in DT.
In DT, the frequency
response we only
ever plotted up to pi because
above pi it repeats itself.
By plotting it between
minus pi and pi,
I've showed a two pi range
and the frequency response
is always periodic in 2 pi
because discrete frequencies
are always periodic in 2 pi.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does
that affect the filters
if the number repeats itself?
DENNIS FREEMAN: How does
that affect the filters?
That's an excellent question
and not a trivial one to answer.
So one of the big
important differences,
which you will
under-appreciate right now,
is that because of
this repetition,
there's no equivalent
thing to bode.
Now I know you all love bode and
because you like it so much--
I'm being slightly sarcastic.
I like it a lot because
it's easy, right?
You haven't quite got
over the barrier yet
and so I've heard some
negative feedback about bode.
Bode's wonderful, but
in case you haven't got
that message, one of the
biggest problems in DT--
which comes about exactly
because of the thing you said--
that the DT frequencies
are periodic.
We don't have an
analog of bode, which
means that when we try
to sketch the magnitude
and phase for a
discrete time filter,
it's a much harder problem.
One for which we almost
always use a computer
because we don't know
any good rules to let us
think about it in our heads.
So that's one of
the implications,
but there's a lot of
others and, in fact, that's
one of the main themes for
the rest of the course.
So the important difference then
is two important differences,
frequency response
lives on the unit circle
and discrete frequencies
are periodic.
OK, I've talked way too
much, so finally I'm
going to ask you
to do something.
I want you to think about
three CT frequencies--
cos 3,000t, cos
4,000t, cos 5,000t--
and think about sampling
them with a sampling
interval capital
T who is at 0.001
and put them in order from
lowest to highest DT frequency.
So first, look at your
neighbor, say hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
DENNIS FREEMAN: And now choose
an answer between 0 and 5.
OK, so which list goes from
lowest to highest DT frequency?
So raise your hand
with the number
of fingers equal to the
answer between 0 and 5.
High, high.
OK, so I see people
disagreeing with their partner.
I think that's always good.
OK, the correct answer
is in the minority.
So let's ask, according
to the theory of lectures,
what's the right answer?
If you were the lecturer
asking this question,
what would you
make the answer be?
AUDIENCE: Probably none of them.
DENNIS FREEMAN: None of them,
except I don't have none--
but that would be the kind
of thing I would do, I guess.
If you were the
lecturer and you wanted
to make a point about x1,
x2, x3, 3,000, 4,000, 5,000--
what would you want
the answer to be?
AUDIENCE: Number 5.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Sure, you'd
like to be number 5, completely
backwards.
OK, talk to your
neighbor-- figure out
why it's completely backwards.
That is the right answer--
the theory of lecturers
always works.
So why is 5 the right answer?
Is 5 the right answer?
5 is the right answer--
why is 5 the right answer?
OK, the corollary to the
theory of lecturers--
always look at the last line.
What was the last point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
wrap [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Things wrap.
So obviously these things
must be wrapping, right,
because according
to the corollary
to the theory of lecturers,
it has to do with wrapping.
According to the theory of
lecturers, it's number 5.
Why would it wrap that way?
Well think about after
you do the sampling,
if you substitute
capital T equals 0.001,
you look up x1 of nT.
So x1 of T is this, so
substitute nT every place there
was a T. So you get 3,000 nT.
3,000 times capital T is 3.
So x1 of n is cos of 3n,
right, and that's written here.
Similarly, the second one is
4n and the third one is 5n.
So the discrete frequency,
capital Omega, is 3, 4, or 5.
Think about where 3, 4, or 5
are on the unit circle, OK?
3 is a number just less than
pi, so that puts 3 here.
4 is a number that's bigger
than pi, so you go around,
you pass pi, and you
go a little further.
And 5 is a number that is
slightly bigger than 3/4
of 2 pi, OK?
So by that logic, right,
this is low frequencies--
positive and negatives
are both necessary because
of Euler's rule.
In order to make a real
value cosine function,
right, we need e to the plus
and we need e to the minus.
So we start at 0 frequency.
As we increase
frequency, we're thinking
about conjugate
frequencies, like so.
So this is the highest
frequency, then they cross--
so which is the highest
frequency among 3, 4, and 5?
Oh, doesn't make any sense.
According to the rules
I just said, the answer
must be 3, right?
3 is closest to
the high frequency,
then the next closest is 4, and
the lowest frequency must be 5.
Why does that make any sense?
The intuition comes from it
if you think it about what's
happening when you're sampling.
Think about what would happen
if capital Omega were a quarter.
Then if we plotted cos omega
t and compared the samples,
cos 0.25n, you would see that
at the discrete frequency,
the samples are a very good
representation of the unsampled
signal.
I'm trying to compare the
CT signal to the DT sampled
signal, OK?
If you changed the discrete
frequency-- if you double it--
you still get a
good representation
of the CT signal.
If you double it again, you
can still see the CT signal.
I'm up to 1--
double it to 2, you can
still sort of see it.
Increase it to 3--
OK, now it's getting a
little harder to see.
Go a little higher to 4--
in this plot, the
red line is showing
the CT signal that was sampled.
Here, the red curve is still
showing the CT signal that
was sampled, but the green curve
is showing an alternative way
to think about that
set of samples.
That set of samples
could alternatively
have come from the
frequency 2 pi minus 4n.
If you go to an even
higher frequency--
if you go to 5, the
problem is even worse.
There's an alternative
way of thinking about it
that's a much lower frequency.
If you go to 6, it's
absurd to think about 6
as being the frequency, right?
The thing that your eyes sees
is this low frequency thing.
You would never guess that I
had sampled the high frequency
thing.
That's what we mean by
the frequencies wrapping.
There are two
different waveforms
that you can sample and
get the same blue circles--
the same samples.
You could sample of
6n or 2 pi minus 6n
and you would get
the same thing.
That's the reason we say that
the discrete frequencies wrap,
OK?
So that's the reasoning
behind thinking about this.
So there's a way of thinking
about 5 as this whole distance
around like that, but
there's another way
of thinking about it as just
the negative frequency coming
this way.
And since they come
in pairs, regardless
of the way I think
about it, I've
always got the pair
there to make sense out
of either interpretation.
That's the hardest part
in DT-- it's not hard,
it's just the hardest part, OK?
If you get that, that's
the only trick in DT.
So the answer then is number 5.
So what kind of
a filter is this?
You remember, we want to
have an intuition just
like if we look at CT, right?
If I told you that I had a CT
and I looked at the s-plane,
and I told you that
there was a pole there--
what kind of a system is that?
High-pass, low-pass,
band-pass, stop-band.
band-pass, what?
CT system, single pole.
Low pass-- it's a low pass
because of bode, right?
Right, you like bode, right?
It's because if we think
about frequencies near 0,
we get one gain and if we
think about frequencies
becoming very large, the gain
falls off linearly after that.
What kind of a
filter is this one?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
Yes, it's a high-pass
filter, right?
It's a high-pass filter
because this pole
is in the denominator,
this vector is large
when we're at DC,
and it's short where
we're into high frequencies
in the denominator,
so that makes the filter be big
for high frequencies compared
to low frequencies, OK?
So that's the only thing
that's different about DT.
OK, in the last 10
minutes what I want to do
is introduce the idea
of a Fourier series
because that's where we're
going with all this junk.
We want to understand DT
frequency responses so that we
can generate a Fourier series.
So the idea is exactly the
same as what we do in CT.
We want to represent a DT signal
as a sum of complex geometrics,
right?
We want to think of it as a sum
of frequencies and the trick
is to find out what that sum is.
The thing that's different
is that frequencies wrap.
Because the frequencies wrap--
in CT the frequencies
don't wrap.
In CT, how many harmonics
do we have to think about
for an arbitrary CT signal?
Infinite, right?
When we think about
a CT Fourier series,
you think about the fundamental,
the second harmonic,
the third harmonic, the fourth,
fifth, sixth, seventh they find
10th, through infinity.
In principle, they all matter.
In DT, because of
the wrapping, there
is a finite number of them.
It's pretty easy to see that--
choose any frequency, assume
that that's periodic in capital
N--
I'm just choosing the period to
be capital N just like we would
say the [INAUDIBLE]
NCT is capital T.
If the signal is
periodic in capital N--
if it was originally a
complex geometric, then--
because of the factoring
properties of the complex
geometric--
it must be the case
that this number,
in order to make it equal to
that-- this number must be 1.
The only way that
number could be 1
would be if capital Omega
is a submultiple of 2 pi.
That means that
if we're thinking
about periodic
signals in 8, there
are exactly eight
frequencies we need
to worry about and no more.
The ninth one aliases
back to the first,
the 10th one aliases back
to the second, et cetera.
There is only eight of them.
That's the big difference
between CT and DT.
In DT, if we were thinking
about sequences of length 3,
there would be three frequencies
we'd have to worry about.
If we were thinking of sequences
of length 4, there's 4.
The number of frequencies and
the number of samples matches.
In fact, that's
not too surprising
because if you just
think about it in terms
of knowns and unknowns, if we
want to represent an arbitrary
signal of length 4 in
terms of frequencies,
we better have four of them--
here they are.
The idea is precisely
the same as CT
except that there is a
finite number of harmonics
that we have to worry about.
The rules for figuring out
what the harmonics are--
and there is also a convenient
way to think about--
DT Fourier series as matrices.
Since we have a finite
number of frequencies
and a finite number
of times, there
is some relation
between the two--
you could have an arbitrary,
linear relationship
between those sets of numbers
expressed by a matrix.
So matrix turns out to be a
very convenient way of thinking
about DT Fourier series.
And there's an orthogonality
principle exactly
like there was in CT.
The orthogonality looks
just like an inner product,
just like it did in CT.
In CT, it was the integral
over any time of length capital
T of the product
of two frequencies
is either 0 or
capital T depending
on whether the frequencies
are the same or different--
same thing happens here.
And because of that,
there is a very simple way
to sift out the k-th
element of the series,
just like there was an
analogously simple way
to sift out the k-th
element of a CT series.
All of this is precisely the
same as what we did in CT.
The result is analysis
and synthesis formulas
that look similar, except there
are sums instead of integrals.
They look just like the CT--
the interesting thing is that
they both have a finite length.
In CT, there was an
infinite sum over k.
In DT, there's a
finite sum over k.
And so that means that there
is a very convenient matrix
way of looking at how would
you construct an arbitrary
signal in time from
frequency components
and how would you compute
the frequency components
from the time components?
It's just that in DT, the
convenient way to express that
relationship-- you can still
express it as an analysis
and synthesis formula--
that's what these are.
But a much more friendly
way of thinking about it
is as a matrix.
Those two representations
are absolutely identical.
So the idea then for today
was generalize CT to DT.
DT is really useful
when you're trying
to do signal processing
with digital electronics.
Digital electronics is the
way to go because they're
so inexpensive and powerful.
So unit circle wrapped,
finite length--
and that finite
length one is really
the key to signal processing
because we can represent
a finite length signal in
time with a finite number
of samples.
There is a match and
that's the reason that's
the method of choice when we
do digital signal processing,
and we'll talk more
about that next time.